[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend und
willkommen Christian
guten Abend und hier sind die
Nachrichten Themen von heute
von der Rebellion zum Rückzug die
russischen Wagner Söldner beenden ihren
bewaffneten Aufstand welche Folgen hat
das für Putin
offenbar Erfolg für die AFD im
thüringischen Sonneberg gewinnt mit
Robert Sesselmann wohl erstmals ein
afd-politiker ein kommunales Spitzenamt
und ein Gewinn für alle zum Ende der
Special Olympics ziehen Athleten
Veranstalter und Fans eine positive
Bilanz
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kaum 24 Stunden Revolte dann war der
Aufstand in Russland plötzlich vorbei
200 km vor Moskau rief der Chef der
wagnergruppe prigoshi gestern Abend
seine Soldaten zurück er wolle kein
russisches Blut vergießen im Gegenzug
verspricht der kremme ihm und seiner
Truppe Straffreiheit ob der 62-Jährige
wie abgesprochen im Exil in Belarus
eingetroffen ist ist offen
sie feiern ihn wie einen Popstar als
wagner-chef brigochine am späten Abend
Roßdorf am Don verlässt wird er wieder
umjubelte Sieger des Tages
heute die Ruhe nach dem Sturm das
militär-hauptquartier wieder unter der
Kontrolle der russischen Armee manche
sind froh darum
wir brauchen die wagnerkämpfer hier in
Rostock nicht früher waren sie Helden
jetzt sind sie niemand mehr für mich
von hier wollten die Wagner Söldner
gestern bis nach Moskau ziehen Putin
droht den Aufständischen
Aufstand vorbereitet haben haben
Russland verraten und werden dafür
bestraft
am Abend im Staatsfernsehen plötzlich
die Meldung der belarussische Präsident
Lukaschenko habe vermittelt Putins
Drohung verpufft
angesichts ihrer Verdienst und
Heldentaten an der Front werden wir sie
immer respektieren sie fragen mich was
mit pregorian persönlich passieren wird
das Strafverfahren gegen ihn wird
eingestellt und er selbst wird nach
Belarus gehen
in Moskau heute erinnert nichts mehr an
die verschärfte Sicherheitslage die
Straßensperren aber die Macht der
russischen Führung scheint angekratzt
das Verteidigungsministerium hat seine
Arbeit gut gemacht aber was passiert ist
hätte wahrscheinlich verhindert werden
können wahrscheinlich werden sich die
paranoiden Tendenzen der russischen
Behörden die jetzt schon ziemlich
ausgeprägt sind noch verstärken
pregorian ist zwar nicht bis nach Moskau
gekommen aber der Tag hatte Risse
offenbart im System Putin
fragen wir unseren Russland
Korrespondenten Christian sem gestern
drohte Putin in den Aufständischen mit
harter Vergeltung jetzt gehen sie
offenbar straffrei aus bröckelt Putins
macht
ja zumindest ist eine Autorität deutlich
angekratzt würde ich sagen er hat ja
gestern eine Rede gehalten und hat den
Verrätern wie er sie nannte harte
Strafen angedroht aber dann war gestern
am Abend war dann eigentlich schon klar
dass brigoshi und seine Kämpfer
straffrei aus der Sache rauskommen
würden und das vor dem Hintergrund und
dass man weiß dass Putin nichts mehr
hast als Verräter also da musste er in
den Gesprächen wohl Zugeständnisse
machen und das schwächt seine Position
was passiert mit pregosch ins 25.000
Soldaten werden die weiter für Russland
kämpfen
das ist noch nicht ganz klar ein Teil
das ist bislang bekannt soll prigoshi
nach Belarus folgen und ihn da
beschützen und möglicherweise auch von
dort operieren anderen Kämpfern den
sollen Verträge vom russischen
Verteidigungsministerium angeboten
werden damit stünden sie dann unter der
Kontrolle des
Verteidigungsministeriums andere sind ja
auch Häftlinge dabei die könnten
möglicherweise in ihre Straflager
zurückkehren ganz klar ist das alles
noch nicht auch wieder die
Verhältnismäßigkeiten aussehen aber ich
bin mir sicher jetzt gehen ist ja sehr
aktiv in seinem Telegramm Kanal wir
werden von ihm hören er wird die Pläne
mitteilen heute haben wir von ihm noch
nichts gehört sein Aufenthaltsort heute
ist nicht bekannt danke schön
Christiansen war das live aus Moskau
nach dem schnellen Ende des
wagneraufstands richten sich die Blicke
auch rasch wieder auf das
Kriegsgeschehen in der Ukraine ob die
Verwerfungen auf russischer Seite den
Verlauf der Kämpfe beeinflussen werden
ist noch nicht absehbar doch die Ukraine
sieht sich ermutigt weiter vor zurück
Rücken von einer Ausweitung der Gegend
Offensive ist die Rede Stefans und
Christian Volk berichten
an der Frontlinie in der Region
saporizia ein us-kamerateam begleitet
ukrainische Soldaten bei ihrem Einsatz
die Kämpfe gehen weiter
wir müssen sie immer wieder aufscheuchen
um sie daran zu erinnern dass sie hier
nicht zu Hause sind
die russischen Truppen aber halten ihre
Stellung das bestätigt am Morgen auch
hier dennoch für die ukrainischen
Soldaten hat das Chaos in Russland neue
Motivation gebracht
wir werden sie besiegen wir drängen sie
alle weg glaub mir
offen bleibt ob die Ereignisse auch
Auswirkungen auf russische Truppen haben
werden
moralisch allerdings ist das schon ein
erheblicher Schlag also man darf nicht
vergessen ist charismatisch er kann die
Fronttruppe durchaus ansprechen und sie
hinter sich versammeln natürlich gibt
das einen Riss und es gibt Zweifel an
der Führungsfähigkeit und wenn sich so
etwas wiederholt dann kann sich die
Zweifel auch vertiefen und natürlich
dann auch zu Einbrüchen führen aber das
ist viel zu früh und das jetzt fest zu
stellen rund um bachmut und auch weiter
südlich an der Ostfront soll die gegen
Offensive vorangekommen sein in der Nähe
von kubianska aber ist es die russische
Armee die von Erfolgen spricht
sie veröffentlicht heute diese Bilder
ukrainische Vorstöße sollen durch
Kampfhubschrauber verhindert worden sein
doch wie so oft in diesem Krieg lassen
sich auch diese Angaben nicht unabhängig
überprüfen
nach Thüringen dort sieht es so aus als
ob erstmals in Deutschland einen
afd-politiker in ein kommunales
Spitzenamt gewählt wurde nach ersten
Zahlen liegt Robert Sesselmann bei der
Stichwahl um den Landratsposten in
Sonneberg vorn schon im ersten Wahlgang
vor zwei Wochen hatten ihm nur wenige
Prozentpunkte zum Sieg gefehlt in
Thüringen wird die AFD vom
Verfassungsschutz als rechtsextrem
eingestuft sesselmanns gegen Kandidat
der amtierende Landrat Jürgen Körper von
der CDU war von einem breiten
Parteienbündnis unterstützt worden
Melanie Haag ist in Sonneberg Melanie
der erste Landrat der AFD was würde
diese Wahl bedeuten
ja also ich muss sagen wir gucken einmal
kurz zurück es fehlt jetzt noch ein
Stimmbezirk sonst sind fast alle 69
ausgezählt und es sieht danach aus dass
der afd-kandidat diese Wahl gewinnen
könnte das würde natürlich bedeuten dass
die AFD damit zum ersten Mal in einem
Amt ist das heißt sie muss Realpolitik
umsetzen und Realpolitik betreiben und
das würde auch bedeuten dass sie die
hohen Erwartungen die die Wähler in sie
gesetzt haben hier zuletzt auch in dem
Wahlkampf erfüllen müsste und das ist
auch mit anderen Fraktionen
zusammenzuarbeiten und das wird wäre
dann die große Aufgabe hier der
afd-kandidaten Sesselmann hatte ja
Wahlkampf gemacht mit bundespolitischen
Themen es ging um die heizungsdebatte um
die ampelpolitik und Flüchtlinge und da
sind dann ist der Wirkungsbereich eines
Landrats natürlich viel geringer und ja
das wäre dann die nächste große Frage
wenn wir hier das Ergebnis haben wir
warten jede Sekunde darauf dann fehlen
noch die Briefwahlunterlagen aber im
Moment sieht es genau danach aus danke
schön nach Sonneberg Melanie Hack war
das
schauen wir nach Bremen da steht jetzt
fest wer das kleinste Bundesland regiert
es bleibt beim Bündnis SPD Grüne und
Links-Partei nach fast vier Wochen
Verhandlungen wollen die Parteien morgen
ihren Koalitionsvertrag vorstellen SPD
Bürgermeister Andreas bovenschulte hatte
sich nach gewonnener Wahl für eine
Neuauflage des Bündnisses entschieden
in Griechenland steht Ministerpräsident
mit zur Tages vor einer weiteren
Amtszeit seine Partei näher Demokratie
hat nach Prognosen die Parlamentswahl im
zweiten Anlauf klar gewonnen die
Konservativen holten demnach wohl die
absolute Mehrheit im Parlament vor fünf
Wochen war ihm das nicht gelungen es kam
auch keine Koalition Zustande deshalb
musste die Wahl wiederholt werden fragen
wir Annette hilsenbeck in Athen warum
haben die Griechen und Griechen in so
gewählt
das Hauptthemen für die Griechen und
Griechen waren wirtschaftlicher
Aufschwung und Stabilität und da haben
sie auf die letzte Amtszeit ist geschaut
da gab es Wirtschaftswachstum da wurden
Renten und Mindestlohn angehoben und die
Arbeitslosenquote wurde um fast halbiert
sein Gegenspieler Alex von der linken
Partei hatte dem in seinem Programm
nicht viel entgegenzusetzen und das viel
diskutierte Schiffsunglück vor der
griechischen Küste bei dem die
griechische Küstenwache schwer unter
schweren Vorwürfen sich ausgesetzt sieht
mal im Wahlkampf kein Thema der wird
sich die neue Regierung nun in eine neue
stellen müssen und für Aufklärung sagen
müssen danke schön für die Informationen
aus Athen Annette hilsenbeck
und damit kommen wir zum Sport zu dir
Christin die Special Olympics in Berlin
gehen heute zu Ende das waren ein
großartiges Fest die
Abschlussveranstaltung zeigen wir ab
kurz vor halb neun im Livestream ZDF
Sportstudio de noch einmal viele
Emotionen nach neuen Wettkampftagen
voller toller Geschichten bei den
Spielen der Glückseligkeit
schon bei der Eröffnungsfeier diese
spontane herzliche Umarmung geradezu ein
Symbolbild für die ehrliche und perfekte
Welt geistig beeinträchtigte Athleten
die weltspieler ein Happening von 7000
Sportlern die erstmals nicht im Abseits
sondern im Fokus standen und das
hoffentlich nachhaltig mein großer
Wunsch ist dass die Spiele im Beitrag
dazu geleistet haben dass alle ein Stück
weit ja vielleicht noch für über die
bestehende Barriere im Kopf nachdenken
was können Menschen mit geistige
Beeinträchtigung für die Gesellschaft
leisten geleistet haben auf die
volontiert ohne die begeisterte mit
Hilfe der 20.000 freiwilligen wäre diese
Veranstaltung und denkbar gewesen dazu
kostenlose medizinische Unterstützung
inklusive Brillen oder Hörgeräte ein
großes soziales Miteinander abseits des
kommerzialisierten Sports und was auf
jeden Fall im Gedächtnis bleibt sind
Bilder ansteckender Lebensfreude
[Applaus]
Platz 3 für die deutsche Leichtathletik
Mannschaft bei der Team EM im Rahmen der
European Games im polnischen horschhof
souverän im Speerwurf Europameister
Julian Weber mit 86 Meter 26 der vierte
Deutsche Einzelerfolg der Gesamtsieg
geht erstmalig an die Mannschaft aus
Italien vor Titelverteidiger und
Gastgeber Polen
ja und zwei weltbeseiten habe ich noch
die gab es beim Triathlon Klassiker in
rot bei den Frauen benötigte die
Schweizerin Daniela rief für 3,8
Kilometer Schwimmen 180 km Rad und in
Marathon 8 Stunden 8 Minuten 21 Sekunden
Platz 32
in 7 Stunden 24 Minuten und 40 Sekunden
so schnell wie keiner zuvor zweiter
wurde andre lange
Respekt vor allem hast recht bei den
Temperaturen absolute Leistung und die
Temperaturen bleiben nicht so zumindest
im Norden gibt es morgen Schauer und
teils kräftige Gewitter im Süden viel
Sonne und nur vereinzelt Blitz und
Donner 23 Grad an der Nordsee bis 33
Grad im Südosten
begrüßt Sie Christian Sievers im heute
journal das 19 Uhr Team sagt danke und
tschüss und wünscht Ihnen einen guten
Start in die neue Woche